what's happening is as the as the
hysteria
around it sort of
dissipates because they can't maintain
it at that level even the people who
ushered in this ridiculous president
this horrible administration who have
pretended everyone else were racist who
taught pretended the squad were decent
people even they now are realizing they
better start making fun of some of this
stuff or they're going to be left in the
dust so here's jimmy fallon i have no
particular feelings about jimmy fallon
he's the nbc tonight show host the
tonight show is a long way away from the
johnny carson tonight show or the jack
park tonight show before that
or the steve allen tonight show before
that i know my history of comedy um
here's jimmy fallon who is obviously a
lefty he's just like a corporate like
you gotta just be a sort of corporate
nothing to get on nbc late night okay is
what it is he's making a lot of money
probably a decent guy actually i
remember when he touched donald trump's
hair remember that years ago he had
donald trump and he touched his hair and
then they tried to cancel him because
you can't make donald trump look like a
human that's that's literally what they
think you're humanizing him you're
humanizing that man
anyway here's jimmy fallon realizing
that the tide's turning so he better
start making fun of biden
let's get to some news on friday
president biden held a controversial
meeting with the crown prince of saudi
arabia but the real controversy was that
biden greeted him with a fist bump
watch this watch this
biden said that wasn't a fist bump that
was me trying to punch him as hard as i
could
it's not a great look it's like a
greeting putin with a chest bump and a
bro hug my man
meanwhile i read that dr fauci said that
he plans to retire by the end of
president biden's term
and then everyone turned to biden like
is there anything you'd like to announce
two
of course once he's gone fast you will
be replaced by a new slightly weaker
variant
okay fine like that's comedy to some
degree i didn't laugh i thought the
street fighter fist thing was kind of
funny um but somebody might have laughed
at that but the point is that the
average person that watches these shows
they might it might start bubbling in
their brain oh maybe joe biden is very
old and confused maybe these fist bumps
instead of handshakes don't make any
sense maybe he should retire because
fouchy's getting out so maybe something
good here is happening that is the point
and then i thought this one was this is
great like this and this is true it is a
joke and it is true this is a tweet from
newsmax this is just spectacular the
place where president joe biden fell off
his bicycle last month in rehoboth beach
delaware has been listed as a historical
landmark called brandon falls
on google maps the washington examiner
reported on tuesday like that's it
people that literally is how we win
i really believe it there will be some
political answers too and you got to
vote for the right people and you got to
live in states that have a chance and
you got to leave states that don't have
a chance but that's how we'll win
that really is how we'll win i really
that's how the culture thing will get
won we lost this
because decent people lost the culture
but we can win this by decent people
grabbing the culture back
foreign